foreign
waiting in Phoenix patiently Frank
welcome to the show
Frank are you Frank are you there
oh hey thanks for taking my call guys
sorry about my phone I'm doing a Dave
Ramsey's uh thing I'm driving a beater
car applying it to a smartphone so it's
not fair enough you got a beater
smartphone what I got it's what I got
yourself you sound fantastic
well thank you I'm in a quandary and I
want your advice on this I've I'm 58
years old never financed anything in my
life
um I've got a pretty good job here and
the car that I had eight months ago
started breaking down I mean every week
was another thousand dollars getting to
the point
of my dependability at work was in
question so I ended up going to a
dealership and getting into the most
horrible deal I had no idea what I
understood is that I was buying a
fifteen thousand dollar car at 24
interest for nineteen eight I agree to
that they said I can make payments early
to pay off the principal and I just work
like it unlike a gazelle right and pay
it off well that's not the case it turns
out I called the finance company about
double three days after taking
possession of the car it is that no Miss
Reynolds I said Frank you uh you owe
thirty thousand dollars not nineteen
thousand dollars and I'm like wait a
minute I didn't agree to this well
here's where we're at so for seven
months I've been making payments every
month never been late
the total hasn't come down at all and
I'm going nowhere and killing myself on
this the warranty expired
you know the dealers
uh seven year hundred thousand that's
gone because of the year now my father
has offered the loan me twenty thousand
dollars for the buyout price of nineteen
eight or whatever it is and he's
probably going to charge me six percent
simple interest
and well that would mean that I'm gonna
end up paying 27 when I Blue Book the
car it came up to ten thousand dollars
not the 15 that they claim so I would
end up paying 27 000 on a ten thousand
dollar car without a warranty now what
I'm thinking is offering them thirteen
thousand tell them to apply to seven
I've already spent and see if they'll
take it if not give them the car back
I don't know if any of it works like
that Frank what Incarnation did you make
a deal with the devil what dealership
was this I might call about myself you
are the spawn of Satan that they really
are that this is you know the thing is a
week later when I talked to them the guy
even told me he knew I didn't know what
I was doing you know like dude you got
raked over the coals how do you even get
a car loan for 24 interest
well I how is that legal I've never
borrowed well there you that's you know
I had a roommate that was an attorney
for once and there's three parts to a
contract and one is what a reasonable
person would expect from a deal and the
meeting of the Mind we've got neither
one of them no boy here's what I'm
looking at what's your income Frank how
do we get out of this mess I signed it I
signed it you know it's not a bad car
don't get me wrong Frank okay Frank
let's start we gotta start breaking this
thing down okay uh what what is your
income George asked you
gosh it it depends uh I'm hourly and
depending like this year we've been
rained out a lot look at about 55. what
do you do
oh this must be the day of the trucker
because I do in a local trucker okay all
right local trucker hourly wage and
you're making about 55 000 a year
that's right do you have any other debt
ah there's depending on what the IRS I
may owe them about 4 000 but that may be
absorbed through those last tax season
I've gotta look how that so you may owe
some IRS back taxes
well yeah well they've been from 2019
but they only claimed one dependent this
year myself so I should have a refund it
will go do that debt okay so that might
be wiped out other than that you have no
debt no credit card debt no personal
loans out there just this car I have a
credit card but that's only for
emergencies
there is no emergency where your money
isn't good and so the goal is for you to
cover it to get me to work because you
know what's going to happen you're going
to get charged 24 interest from the
credit card company as soon as you don't
play their game perfectly
oh I don't use their I honestly I'm 57
I've never used credit in my life then
cut it out I don't use that card you
haven't needed it for 58 years you don't
need it now all right we got to get rid
of this car so what is the car worth I
want out of this have you done good
homework on what the car is actually
worth today uh 10 10 5. and you owe what
there were so many numbers flying around
what what do you oh what is your actual
loan currently 19 19
uh eight or nineteen six would be the
buyout okay
so
this car you are underwater on
by a degree of about nine thousand
dollars right right that's right okay
how much money do you have in the bank
uh maybe the thousand dollar emergency
after the first uh with those round of
rent utilities and all that are you
single hey man yeah yes okay where is
all of your money going you make 55k
you've got the thousand dollar emergency
fund where's your monthly income going
outside of the car payment
oh honestly I am I am a zealous listener
of your program uh in fact just uh read
the book uh Total Money Makeover a lot
of it went to repairs in the previous
car you add in rent of well it's 12.50 a
month Frank do you think you could go to
a credit union today and get a 9 000
loan
I don't think so I've never applied for
a loan okay um here's the way out of
this I'm not going to go into debt with
Dad at six percent and move this money
around here's the best plan you need to
save up and get a beater car you need to
borrow one from a friend if you've got a
local Church community see how cheaply
you can get a reliable car and save up
to that amount I have I own a car
outright okay you have another car
what's that car doing where is that car
whole reason I got into this is because
Frank everywhere where's the other car
oh sir sir let's let me explain we don't
have we have 30 seconds we got a
commercial we got to get to
I got you use the other car sell the car
today not Dependable it doesn't matter
we'll sell that one and get some of that
is Dependable but going 30 grand into
debt at 24 interest is not the path out
of this thing so you need to go to the
credit union get the difference you need
to pay that loan off to sell the car and
drive that beater until you're out of
this mess
whoo that was an entertaining doozy Ken
love talking to Frank but man I need a I
need a break
I'll get you some Tums